[Musique]
voilà notre cible d'après mon indique si
fiat se procurer la technologie qui
permet de créer des ports salle
le ministère des affaires étangères
envoyé un message urgent il ya eu un
coup d'état hoyé were le commandement
naval nous demande de mettre le cap sur
le wiiware et d'évacuer tous leurs
ressortissants
s'il pense la secourir ils vont pas être
déçus
il se courront un cadavre au mortier
sa volonté
cette mission vise aussi à envoyer un
message fort à tous les terroristes
il ne faut pas s'en prendre aux citoyens
chinois
comment dans l'art kerry anne il est
pointé vers nous préparez vous à passer
à l'offensive
[Musique]